Speaker 1: I got a ton of emails over the weekend
and yesterday and today saying, David, you're not
going to cover the Chris Cuomo thing because
you're a Democrat and he's a Democrat and you
run interference for CNN and blah blah blah. Have
you ever seen this show before? Because that's a
No. One. I'm not a Democrat. Number two, I don't
care about the Democratic Party. Number three,
I don't even watch corporate media, with the
exception of clips that are sent to me for
things I might cover on the show. I don't really
care what's happening. I don't care about CNN.
I don't care about running interference for CNN.
I don't know if Chris Cuomo is a Democrat. I know
his brother, the former governor of New York, is
a Democrat. Is Chris Cuomo a Democrat? Maybe me. I
don't care. It makes no difference to me. And the
Chris Cuomo story is a very important media story.
And the story is, by the way, as we already talked
about on yesterday's bonus show. The story is that
while Andrew Cuomo, the former governor
of New York, was being hit with allegation
after allegation of sexual assault. Chris Cuomo,
CNN anchor, was using his media sources to find
information about the accusers and was giving that
information to a top aide for Andrew Cuomo and
sort of helping to craft a response, a public
response to the allegations. Now, of course, you
would expect if you have a brother who knows about
how things play in media and has access, you would
expect that he's going to try to help you. The
question, of course, is about the appropriateness
of him being on air at all, on CNN, on air, on
CNN, sometimes interviewing his brother. And CNN
has now suspended Chris Cuomo indefinitely, and
it is obviously the right decision with sir. What
are you're not defending, guys? I don't care. I
don't care about the Partizan stuff. I don't even
necessarily see this as that. This is
just completely inappropriate. New York
Times article explains CNN suspends Chris Cuomo
after new details on help he gave his brother
the cable news networks top rated anchor
was an intimate adviser to Andrew Cuomo
in the last 18 months of his governorship. The CNN
anchor, Chris Cuomo, suspended indefinitely by the
network yesterday after new details emerged about
his efforts to assist Andrew Cuomo, his brother,
as he faced a cascade of sexual harassment
accusations. Cuomo previously apologized for
advising Andrew Cuomo senior political aides
a breach of traditional barriers between
journalists and lawmakers, but thousands of pages
of evidence released Monday by the New York. AG
revealed that the anchors role was more
intimate and involved than previously known.
Mr Cuomo's entanglement with the last 18 months
of his brother's governorship has proved a slow
moving headache for CNN, which has stood
by its top rated anchor even as a drip of
uncomfortable revelations, raised questions about
the network's adherence to journalistic standards.
Jeff Zucker, CNN's president, supported Cuomo for
months, declining to discipline him, even after
reports showed he was in strategy sessions with
his brother's political team. A breach of basic
reportorial conduct Earlier this year, the network
floated the idea that he could take a temporary
leave if he really wanted to focus formally on
helping Andrew Cuomo. But now a very harsh set of
facts came out. We talked a little bit about this
on the bonus show in scores of emails and text
messages between Chris Cuomo and his brother's
inner circle. He repeatedly offered advice. Let
me help you with prep, he texted a senior aide. He
made efforts to track down the status of pending
articles about the sexual assault allegations
at harassment allegations at one point.
The governor's former top aide, Melissa DeRosa,
asked the anchor if he could check his sources on
a rumor that Politico was working on a story with
more accusations on it. Chris Cuomo responded.
Also includes a report, the report includes
a text from Cuomo to the adviser DeRosa
sent a few days after a woman, Anna Ruk, told
the New York Times that Cuomo made an unwanted
advance toward her at a wedding. I have a lead on
the wedding girl, Chris Cuomo wrote in the text.
Chris Cuomo later told told investigators he heard
from a friend that quote. Maybe she had been put
up to it. So listen, this is obviously the correct
decision from CNN. You're not going to find me
defending any of these actions. This is completely
inappropriate. There are broader questions in
terms of, you know, the interviews that Chris
Cuomo would do with Andrew Cuomo, which were
basically softball interviews. And sometimes there
would be sort of like, OK, now I got to ask you
a real question, even though you're my brother, I
got to ask you a serious question. It's just all,
not really journalism. And that was a problem from
day one. And this is just completely over-the-top,
inappropriate. So if you're surprised
that this is the position I'm taking,
I guess you don't know me. You don't know my show,
but I don't know how at this point. Chris Cuomo
can really be on CNN in a serious and credible way
that doesn't mean his career is over. I mean, look
at Brian Williams making up war stories and then
goes away for a while and just comes back. Look
at Jeffrey Toobin caught masturbating on a Zoom
meeting and he had to be removed from the air.
And he's quietly back, and so it's not over for
Chris Cuomo. But this is completely inappropriate.
And if there's any criticism here, it's CNN didn't
act quickly enough, although this is obviously
the right decision if you disagree. Let me know.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman and tell me.
As a reminder, we are now under two weeks from
the next David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall.
All are welcome member or not. All are welcome
to participate. It will be December 14th
at six p.m. Eastern Time. It will be live only
on the Pacman Live YouTube channel. That's the
second YouTube channel. Make sure you subscribe
there. It's free, and if you want a better shot
of getting on with me, sign up at Join Pacman dot
com as our members do get priority, but it is open
to all looking very much forward to it. We'll
take a quick break and be back right after this.